so he's going to go backwards right from
my thrust or at least my thrust is
coming that way so by default that means
he has to be coming
forward on My ATT so it's not that I go
here he goes go well it's not that I'm
here and then I let him stop and then I
come back okay so you have to feel the
you established the iy at the front so
when he goes you're already off of it
not
and then I try to go I actually got
checked out okay so you have to feel for
that and then you're just
in and there's no tension in what you're
doing okay so what's he doing boom
in so you have a clearing of defense and
then attack up down the center l okay
reconcile Yin boom and come in the
void so Yin reconciliation boom and then
in the void okay all right let's
go
so uh
geomet speaking he has a line of attack
he's going to uh have some sort of
linearity to it so the linearity is
going to require my circle okay so just
like on the other one I yielded with the
circle I always yield on the circle so
here if you're fine don't worry okay I'm
going to go I have to go around this
thing so I'm going to go around it with
my body
okay not that I'm just on the side going
here I meet
this with
circles
okay and again the same thing you can't
know that's too late okay it's the same
body reading that you're
doing same body
body the
defang then
Pi again don't start so far close close
[Music]
close let's
try
so just like on the sword technique the
circle it allows you to keep coming in
remember I need you to come in okay so
as he's going here I go linear you're
not motivated to come in okay my my
circle is going this
way it's a circle
whoa not
here you're just doing that cuz it's
safer all right but it's a circle again
if you're reading the body you know when
he's going to go you're just you're
actually waiting okay so I'm here and
I'm waiting if you pay attention I've
already moved watch when I touched his
arm watch when my blade goes to his arm
okay
so and then watch his watch his spine in
space okay we're still coming forward
when the knife goes into it okay try it
again all right so there's two size to
the circle that's the cool thing about
using circles okay so if we take this
one arm and I'm coming here you're going
to go one and instead of going back on a
straight line it's here boom this way
okay that's what you're trying to do so
as he's coming in boom it helps keep
from coming in okay he's is coming
in if you look for example I on me right
[Music]
in always got to use the other side of
the
circle so that's what that has doing
both
in if he's not there because he's coming
in so fast then it's in your angle of
Defense you see so it's got an angle
across the arm I'm not I'm not over here
okay
so sometimes you touch him it depends
how fast he's coming in
okay then the other arm the same thing
so this was feeding the
defang
okay this way think of the circle
vertical now after it does its feeding
then it continues on the downside and
brings the check
in so this hand more
here start so
far okay so same principles though you
you're still going to have your uh
ground vectoring do you see I still have
it when I enter I'm still in your Center
do you see so you can
project okay and then the same thing
when I stab I'm not Like This Hold the
End Hold the End okay it's same thing
you're still doing the same thrust with
the ground Ving okay so same thing here
you have your adhesion do you see that
adhesion brings him
in now you're just sophisticating it
with the other
hand okay try that again okay so again
the yield is on the circle use
and that Circle tactically helps pull
the guy in okay
um so let's do a right cross this time
so right straight cross boom you Shuffle
in and everything right boom okay so
maybe over
here instead of leaving
straight I'll make that same
Circle it goes back you see I I combine
it and I'm now moving in so I sucker him
in and then come in and I'll come up
with that reverse hammerfist down on the
groin okay so if I hit the groin see how
he kind of bends over like that and then
you follow the rule that we've been
doing we Circle where the circle ends
the line begins and you so you have
continuous motion okay so where the
circle ends the line begins boom you're
here and we'll come back around will hit
this kidney back
here so if you watch my body my body is
just
okay around and then I'm going drop back
on the M
okay so I'm here
in there it is it's got to be small
don't miss on purpose please okay Bo
that's what I'm
doing and then I hit
it okay let's try it
all right so uh on the strikes very much
like the knife it's across so don't
shuffle through okay it's here right
you're go ahead you're reading the body
you understand you have to have that
skill but I'm setting up for this low
Target some very common on boxers
because they're not used to protecting
their lower Target okay so I set this up
so I'm here I set it up
okay and my hand as my body's going this
way watch what my hand does I round that
corner and I come in and hit boom in
okay keep this hand going
okay and it's the same grounding that
you're going to do so uh go ahead leave
your hand out just leave your hand out
right I'm not out here and I'm swinging
something stay up I'm not going to hit
you okay my my body is is moving forward
do you get what I'm saying I'm grounding
and my whole mass is hitting not back
here okay my whole body is going to
everything is hitting okay so likewise
when I hitch here I won't I won't hitch
you but my hand is heavy just like on
the last video we did on the jodan I tyo
remember my heavy hand oh my hand is
heavy and my body is going to settle oh
okay and then same thing over here come
around I'm not going to
go my body boom is hitting
okay so that means as I'm go in like I
have to have the connection with the
ground okay I have
to that will get then give me a friction
here you see and I use that
check boom there's a check on this hand
on the other side of the circle I come
around check on this hand on the other
side of the circle just like the knife
technique so I'm not going to go like
this
Boom the other hand on the other side of
the circle is checking boom pop boom
okay bring those in and bring those
internal aspects in okay so uh what we
did in the sword is as he was attacking
now I was attacking same thing on the
knife as he was attacking I was
attacking so when he comes here and he
does the punch he attacks back and then
I go no no no I have to hit him as he's
as his fist is coming out no too late
right that's just a weave and get out
okay this is a set up from the start
boom as as his punch is coming out you
should have already knocked his
testicles into his pelvis okay you guys
understand that so do it again I'm here
no too late you should dance out you got
to weave in there I'm setting a piece of
tack I'm hitting him as his fist is
still flying with that single intention
of hitting me okay try it again all
right these are not pitter patter stries
these
are um the same deconstruction you
always use on someone's base okay so
when I when I drop this I'm not trying
to kiss the surface of this kidney I'm
hitting at a kidney angle that generates
that knee band okay so not where his
feet are and I'm doing it with my body
so I'm not here like that my body drops
is what I'm trying to do when I think
you guys see that and then I don't I
don't I don't want to show it cuz it's
even greater because the target is even
more vulnerable when you're here on the
head so I'll move it back a little but
it's the same thing he'd have more
Buckle right and this would be more bent
and that's what boom is dropping down
where he you now you deconstructed but
it's the same technique don't hit the
surface drop your weight is but you're
doing all those strikes okay you guys do
you understand okay so take that away
please when you're going
slow have good
mechanics feel that you could put your
weight on that oh you could put your
weight on that so likewise just like in
y man your elbow comes in your elbow
comes in first your elbow comes in first
boom okay you don't have your elbow
last this way that actually hurts when
you hit something really hard it hurts
across your elbow here like and you
start generating like tennis elbow okay
all right try to okay so same tactic
from the clench right and I we'll go
back if I drive on him a lot of people
drive back they're probably not going to
push me all the way across the mat but
that first drive he'll resist it okay
actually stop doing iido and resist the
Dr there you go okay so as I feel that
that energy is where I do the circle
okay and don't change your hands your
hand you don't have to do the classic
teni nog hands or have his neck you
already have his body go back you
already have his body you're you're
already in his Center
okay so I push he drives and P you have
it so in you got to be in the center you
see I drive I feel his resistance for
and I use the same Circle okay oh you
all right yeah
for
okay let's
go
all the techniques right I can't wait
till he did his thing and completed it
my move is in in the middle of his move
so it's not that I'm here I push he
pushes and then I try to go okay it's
right as As I push he pushes that's
where I yield right right at the little
seat of
that and then like all these techniques
because we're making him do the back
outward kazushi he his Center has to be
going forward okay meaning I'm not going
to go
here his Center I drive he drives his
Center is going
forward I don't stop it from going
forward and the in heel the circle keeps
it Center going forward so the more that
you stop his Center going forward the
less he's in the technique you have to
let him go
forward so he
drive want him to go
forward
okay try it
again